hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
daher gerade immer noch etwas so ist
habe ich mir gedacht mach ich mal wieder
ein rezept bfb und zwar gibt es einen
objekt orte aus dem kühlschrank das
heißt ihr braucht keinen backofen
sondern nur einen kühlschrank und zwar
ist diese show große torte daraus
entstanden
der boden besteht aus konflikt und
mantel splittern und schokolade und das
ist eben dieser schoko profis tiger sind
die alle diese kleinen teile die habe
ich auch hier oben drauf noch mal
gesetzt dann habe ich ganz viele
erdbeeren im innern und eine richtig
leckere creme aus frischkäse und
mascarpone ich also ich werde jetzt
liebt es wenn der boden so quandt total
super
seifenblasen schon da und die torte ist
wirklich ganz einfach zu machen man
braucht nicht viele zutaten nicht für
werkzeug deswegen legen wir direkt los
und ich zeige euch die zutaten für den
shop frau sie zeigen für den shop profis
boten natürlich für den genuss verboten
brauchen wir 80 cornflakes die sind
umgesetzt 50 gramm mandeln die sind
geschüttet 150 gramm butter schokolade
oder kuvertüre und zehn gramm kokosfett
ich nehme zuerst die kuvertüre und hier
habe ich bereits wasser erwärmt vorhin
und habe es wieder ausgestellt und kann
jetzt zwei drittel der kuvertüre in ein
wasserbad geben
das ist jetzt wieder die impf methode
als ich werde die kuvertüre temperieren
damit sie später keinen grauschleier
bekommt jetzt wird die schokolade hier
erst einmal erwärmt beziehungsweise
geschmolzen und die kuvertüre kommt dann
später auf etwa 30 grad als 30 grad und
ist dann schön glänzen
und dann kann ich sie eben schon
verarbeiten so hat die kuvertüre jetzt
etwa 50 grad und jetzt muss ich sie
wieder abkühlen
das heißt ich gibt es restliche drittel
kuvertüre mit dazu und verrührt es jetzt
so lange bis sie sich komplett aufgelöst
hat und so könnte dann auf etwa 29 30
grad
da
sobald die kuvertüre geschmolzen ist
gebe ich jetzt noch das kokosfett mit
rein und zwar sorgt das später dafür
dass die kuvertüre nicht mehr zu
festwirt und ich später diesen kram
spuren auch gut durch schneiden kann
jetzt fühle ich die kurve in eine
größere schale
da kann ich sie jetzt gut mit den
cornflakes und mit den mantel spiel zu
vermengen
und jetzt rührt er die zutaten so lange
miteinander es keine konflikte mehr ohne
schokolade ba sind also die müssen alle
gut mit der schokolade um handys sein
und bevor ich jetzt diese masse in den
boden rein fühle werde ich jetzt erst
mal zwölf kleine häufchen hieraus noch
hinsetzen
denn die brauche ich später für die
dekoration und das mache ich mir zwei
teelöffel einfach schöne kleine und die
setzt sich dann direkt hier drauf und
dann ist jetzt auch sehr schnell
arbeiten denn dadurch dass die kuvertüre
jetzt temperiert ist wird es sehr
schnell fest
jetzt ist bei mir mittlerweile die masse
wieder fest das heißt ich stelle sie
ganz kurz ins wasserbad erwärmt sie sich
wieder kurz und dann kann ich die masse
in den bug haben füllen
den habe ich übrigens bereits auf 24 cm
durchmesser eingestellt
natürlich die maße direkt in den bug
rahmen hinein und falls jetzt keine ba
gramm habt könnt ihr natürlich auch eine
springform nehmen aber mit dem bug haben
eignet sich besser reihe später noch
eine creme mit reinkommen und der ball
kam dann einfach dieser tortenring ist
kann ich die masse direkt mit einem glas
fest drücken
und da macht es auch nichts wenn ihr die
komplex ein bisschen zerstört
die schoko profis setzte jetzt nur auf
einen separaten teller sich bei allen
die mir gleich beim transport raus und
jetzt kann ich die torte in den
kühlschrank stellen
und in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
klingen vorbereiten für die creme
brauche ich 400 milliliter schlagsahne
vier teelöffel seiner fahrt 500 gramm
magerquark 400 g frischkäse ich habe
ziele philadelphia im doppel am stufe
noch mal fünf teelöffel salat 150 gramm
puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt und
ein paar frische erdbeeren
ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal die sahne
steif schlagen die muss ich jetzt kurz
verrühren dann dass seine partner mit
ein und schlage dann steigt
die sache habe ich kurz kühl gestellt
und kann jetzt die restlichen zutaten
also frischkäse und quark in einem
separaten schlüsselproblem da kommt der
puderzucker noch mit dazu dann auch das
restliche seiner partei prüfe und etwas
vanille extrakt für den geschmack und es
wird jetzt kurz verrührt bis ich die
zutaten gut verbunden haben
die kriegen habe ich jetzt auch kurz
kühl gestellt und kann jetzt in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die erdbeeren
vorbereiten und zwar wird der grüne stil
weggeschnitten
einen teil der erdbeeren werde ich jetzt
halbieren die kommen nämlich direkt in
den tortenring an den rand dann sieht
nämlich der hand richtig hübsch aus
wenig später den toten raum und entferne
jetzt kann ich die sahne unter die
restliche creme heben
einen kleinen teil der creme verstreiche
ich jetzt direkt auf dem trockenboden
und zwar kleben dann erdbeer nämlich
schön dran
das kann man am besten mit einer
tankkarte verstreichen oder mit dem
löffel zum beispiel
und ihr pflege ich die erdbeer mit der
schnittkante nach außen in die formel 1
einmal ringsherum
und die restlichen etwa verteile ich
jetzt einfach in der mitte und zwar so
dass wirklich komplett der ganze boden
bedeckt ist
jetzt bedecke ich die s bahn mit der
restlichen creme
jetzt die creme oben so ein bisschen
weil ich als ich stress jetzt nicht ganz
glatt decke die torte jetzt mit einem
top bretter ab und dann muss sie für
mindestens 4 stunden in den kühlschrank
die tat sitzt gut durchs gefühlt jetzt
habe ich sie auf eine tortenplatte
gesetzt dann kann man nämlich den torten
rente retter darunter wegnehmen und auch
das passt hier manchmal den deckel weg
und ist backpapier kann sich oben immer
ein
man kann es mir nicht um verdeckte als
nächstes lösegeld roten raben mit einem
messer
und jetzt wird die torte noch fertig
dekoriert dafür habe ich jetzt noch ein
paar erdbeeren mit grün und die schoko
groß ist und ein paar minzblättern die
erdbeeren welche halbieren und dann
draufsetzen
die torte sitzt dekorierten jetzt können
wir sie direkt am schneiden uns
probieren warte du darfst erst klauen
wenigsten paar wochen teller woche gehe
wir brauchen endlich ein richtig
scharfes messer dafür denn der boden ist
sehr knusprig und sehr fest
die radiosendung mit dem kleinen nils
kentsch ist diese stimme den kleinen
nils also der vorteil bei seiner tat ist
natürlich man kann sie dekorieren wie
man möchte
der nachteil wenn man sie nicht so
ordentlich drauf legt ist dass man immer
gucken muss überschneidet das hört man
schon richtig geld
das ist meins das ist vorbei ich hab sie
glauben nicht alle hunde ja aber du hast
doch das ganze
die ganzen erdbeeren ganzen show großes
rüber geklaut also normalerweise ihre
schöne aus danke samira der mannes runde
geklaut aber ich freue mich jetzt auf
dem boden
man muss gestehen ich habe die torte
jetzt nicht ganz vier stunden fühlen
lassen wenn man sie komplett können
lästig sind ein bisschen fester
aber die social festigung der boni ist
echt göttlich ohne witz sind sehr gut
richtig gut was willst du frisch creme
fraiche frischgemüse ein bisschen
salziger ist aber nie sagte er liegt es
ist nicht salzig soll das gleichzeitig
voll ist gleichwohl aus als ich glaube
ohne dieses bisschen diese note salzige
wäre zu süß aber richtig tolle torte vor
allem für den sommer man könnte sie
theoretisch auch einfrieren und zum
beispiel als eistorte verlieren hätte
ich vielleicht sogar nochmal besser so
leicht gefroren
noch was sagen oder willst einfach
fertig los die höheren fällen dürfen
ich habe alles mobilisieren das
beschreibt einfach genial
der boden wirklich richtig grantig
falls es auch lust auf diese torte
bekommen macht dann geht auch das blog
de da stets noch mal ganz genau sanierer
und murat die familie noch ein bisschen
studiums orte und ich freue mich nach
machen wenn ich ganz viel spaß machen
bis zum nächsten mal
doch besiegen